sur la côte atlantique de la bretagne au
pays basque
ces plages sont devenus des cimetières
pour dauphin depuis le début de l'année
plus de 1000 dauphins se sont échoués
sur ses plages et pour les scientifiques
en réalité il serait dix fois plus
nombreux à mourir dans les filets des
bateaux de pêche militants écolos contre
pêcheurs la situation est de plus en
plus tendue
m
sacré coeur de pêcheurs dauphin faut pas
s'imaginer que
on en a rien à [ __ ]
on voit tous ses hématomes
importants qui sont liées à l'agonie de
l'animal en profondeur dans l'engin de
pêche faut absolument réduire les
captures de manière importante et
rapidement si on veut pas constater le
déclin dans les populations le jour on
constatera le déclin il sera trop tard
pour bouton a embarqué à bord du sam
simon un patrouilleur de los angeles sea
shepherd
ces patrouilleurs est là pour sauver un
maximum de dauphin l'om jesse shepherd
c'est une ong créée en 1977 par paul
watson
ce canadien est devenu célèbre pour ses
actions sur tous les océans
non mais
la marque de fabrique de sea shepherd
c'est des actions coup de poing contre
les pêcheurs
alors
le premier danger pour les dauphins
c'est la pêche intensive dans le golfe
de gascogne un bateau peut dérouler
jusqu'à 100 kilomètres de filets sauf
que dans cette zone il y as 400 bateaux
de pêche soit quarante mille kilomètres
de filets autant de pièges mortels pour
les dauphins on a embarqué plusieurs
jours avec céline et thomas pour sea
shepherd il dirige les opérations
[Musique]
on a plusieurs fils ailleurs qui sont
moins coin des gros fileyeurs et on a
des fortes suspicions enfin les
scientifiques aussi que c'est le type de
filet qui pourrait prendre pas mal de
dauphin on va aller voir la remontée des
filets
ben
simon
je sais
[Musique]
ici embarcations sea shepherd pour vous
prévu une baisse des tarifs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est là pour observer plusieurs types
de pêche parce qu'on est là pour
comprendre
premièrement pour expliquer les chiffres
que les scientifiques donnent on sait
pas vraiment lequel remonte plus de
dauphin donc on est vraiment là pour
apprendre un maximum l'eau et la boue et
qui marque la fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
ici embarcations de l'orangé sea
shepherd nous arrivons à votre bâbord
pour observer
voilà je les ai contactés pour leur
faire dire qu'on arrive et nous au salut
et voilà ça se passe bien des fois où
c'est plus tendu fois y'a des fois c'est
plus tendu
j'ai été reçu
on ne peut pas nier 90% de des dauphins
échoués sont dus à une prise
accidentelle par la pêche oui oui c'est
un crève coeur de pêcher un dauphin faut
pas s'imaginer que on en a rien à [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
les pêcheurs disent ne pas pouvoir
changer de méthode
lohan jesse j'ai peur devait donc
imposer la présence de caméras sur
chaque bateau est filmé la remontée de
chaque filet pour les scientifiques qui
autopsie les dauphins il ya urgence si
on ne change rien l'espèce va
disparaître du golfe de gascogne
alors le tout c'est de la méthode
voilà un tube relié les retours quand il
glisse à l'envers la dent le chalut
et tu vois après on sait que des grosses
marques de cornes bout cerclage doit
autour de l'abdomen
on en a vu sur le terrain peut-être
trois autres de caudal coupé on est dans
ce qu'on appelle - un pic de des choix
de multiples donc avec une mortalité
importante et qui est liée notamment à
des activités humaines
quand même pas mal amoché aller pour les
passer par dessus bord il utilise un
treuil ou un palan à main et donc ils
accrochent l'animal par la caudale il le
soulève pour passer par dessus le bord
du bateau et pour que l'animal en fait
soit remis à l'eau est donc plutôt que
de couper le goûter et couple à la
caudale les examens qu'on comporte c'est
pour essayer de catégoriser l'engin de
pêche ce qui est plus compliqué donc on
essaie de relever des indices pour pour
ça on a eu des trans comme ça qu'ils
partent en biais je pense qu'ils comme
sur l'autre individu qui est là il doit
passer un bouton au tour ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que ça fait quatre ans
que chaque année est pire que la
précédente
les données qu'on a nous indiquent qu'il
ya pas plus de dauphins dans la zone qui
a 10 ans en revanche on pense qu'ils se
sont un peu plus rassemblés près des
côtes où il ya le plus de pêche sur
certains poissons
donc on pense que tout ce monde-là mange
au même endroit et que du coup au moment
où les engins de pêche passe pour pêcher
le poisson
eh bien il ya des captures de dauphin
qui se produisent en faut absolument
réduire les captures de manière
importante et rapidement si on veut pas
constater le déclin dans les populations
le jour on constatera le déclin il sera
trop tard
[Musique]